y el cirujano puede realizar una funda
aplicación para tratar una enfermedad
por reflujo gastroesofágico o para
reparar una hernia hiatal
y la digestión comienza en la boca
cuando los dientes trituran los
alimentos en pequeños trozos la saliva
libera enzimas digestivas cuando se
ingieren alimentos éstos ingresan al
esófago un tubo muscular largo que
traslada a los alimentos de la boca al
estómago para continuar la digestión las
contracciones denominadas perista lisis
empujan los alimentos hacia el esófago
en la parte inferior del esófago los
alimentos atraviesan la válvula muscular
llamada esfínter esofágico inferior o ls
e ingresan al estómago los jugos
digestivos segregados por el estómago
son elevadamente ácidos cuando el
estómago se contrae para pasar los
alimentos al intestino el ls se cierra
estrechamente a fin de evitar que esos
jugos ácidos regresen al esófago donde
pueden causar daño
un músculo respiratorio llamado
diafragma separa el pecho del abdomen
para llegar al estómago el esófago
atraviesa el diafragma en un punto
llamado 'anillo y a tal
si padece la enfermedad por reflujo
gastroesofágico gerd el ls no se cierra
adecuadamente dejando que los contenidos
ácidos del estómago vuelvan al esófago
si la gente no es tratada puede producir
diversos problemas esofágicos entre
ellos úlceras sangrado estenosis o
estrechamientos y el esófago de barrett
que es el crecimiento anormal de células
tipo intestinal en el esófago que pueden
producir cáncer si usted tiene una
hernia hiatal una parte del estómago
está sobresaliendo hacia la cavidad del
pecho a través de la abertura del
diafragma una hernia hiatal puede
afectar el ls e incrementar el riesgo y
la gravedad de la health
antes de iniciar el procedimiento se le
introducirá una vía intravenosa en el
brazo para proporcionarle líquidos y
medicamentos es posible que se le coloca
un catéter en la vejiga para drenar la
orina se le administrara anestesia
general que lo dormirá durante todo el
procedimiento una vez dormido se le
insertará un tubo respiratorio por la
boca y en la tráquea para ayudarlo a
respirar durante la operación
para una funda aplicación se puede
utilizar uno de los dos métodos en el
procedimiento abierto tradicional
el cirujano comenzará haciendo una
incisión de 8 pulgadas 20 centímetros en
el abdomen para dejar a la vista el
estómago y el esófago inferior después
de separarlo de las estructuras cercanas
el cirujano en volver a el fondo o parte
superior del estómago alrededor del
esófago inferior y lo suturar a esta
envoltura actúa como un cinturón que
ajusta y refuerza el ls
en el procedimiento laparoscópico el
cirujano comenzará haciendo cinco
pequeñas incisiones clave de
aproximadamente media pulgada 13
centímetros de largo en el abdomen a
través de una incisión el cirujano
insertará en laparoscopia un tubo largo
y delgado que contiene una linterna y
una cámara la cámara envía imágenes a
una pantalla de vídeo para que el
cirujano las vea se bombeará gas para
inflar el abdomen a fin de que el
cirujano vea los órganos internos con
mayor claridad a través de otras
incisiones el cirujano usará
instrumentos para separar el fondo del
estómago de los alrededores envolverlo
alrededor del esófago inferior y suturar
lo
si usted tiene una hernia hiatal el
cirujano empujar a la parte hernia da
del estómago hacia el abdomen y ajustará
el anillo y atal en el diafragma para
evitar otra hernia se puede realizar a
través de un procedimiento abierto o
laparoscópica
para finalizar la cirugía las incisiones
abdominales se cierran con puntos o
grapas
cuando se despierte de la cirugía
encontrará un pequeño tubo que irá desde
la nariz hacia el interior del estómago
este tubo ayuda a extraer los líquidos y
gases del lugar de la cirugía y por lo
general es retirado a los dos días se lo
alentará a salir de la cama y a comenzar
a caminar el mismo día de la cirugía